les entrepôts du port
second port créé à la réunion après
celui de saint pierre le port en eau
profonde de la pointe des galets est
inaugurée en 1886 des drags
d'impressionnantes machines inspirées de
celles ayant creusé de canal de suez
fouille le sable au créé 16 hectares de
bassins en 1886 il n'existe pas encore
de quai mais des affrontements en bois
sur lesquels se trouvent des machines à
vapeur destinée à la manipulation des
marchandises progressivement des
entrepôts sont construits autour des
bassins dont ces trois bâtiments au plan
original entre les deux d'ars
on aménage un terre-plein de 86 mètres
de large
l'abus de terre d'origine et décaissé
afin que le niveau côté bassin soit plus
bas que celui côté terre plein on y
construit à l'heure en étage côté d'ars
et en simple rez-de-chaussée à l'arrière
implanté en plein coeur du port de la
pointe des galets ces trois bâtiments
initialement conçue en bois ont été
plusieurs fois transformé reconstruit en
béton dans les années 1960
il accueillait à l'origine les bacs de
sucre destiné à l'export descendu
jusqu'au niveau du quai grâce à un
ingénieux système de trappe c'est de
rang elles étaient acheminés via les
rails de chemin de fer installé sur
l'esplanade
ces trois édifices ne sont plus
aujourd'hui que partiellement occupée
notamment par le service maintenance du
grand port maritime dans le cadre du
grand projet de renouvellement urbain de
la vie du port visant à ouvrir la ville
sur la mer ils devraient être
réhabilités et trouver ainsi un nouveau
souffle